die boßeler ich bin im serverraum
instagram us unbewusstes käsekuchen gibt
die wackel guck mal hier kommt der
gerade ganz frisch aus dem ofen noch
video wie das paket deutschland nicht in
japan ist diese art von käsekuchen schon
seit längerem berühmt und ich habe
einige erfolglose rezepte ausgetestet
die sind leider misslungen
aber jetzt habe ich das perfekte rezept
für euch
als erstes nehmen wir uns unser
backpapier und teilen das einmal in der
hälfte durch anschließend schneiden wir
unten dünne streifen ein
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir eine 18 cm
springform und fette sie mit back trend
spray oder butter ein und gebe das
backpapier an den rand zusätzlich gebe
ich ein stück backpapier auf dem boden
danach nehme ich mein langes stück
alufolie und falte das zweimal in der
mitte dann lege ich das einmal um die
springform herum an zutaten brauchen wir
sechs eigelbe sechsmal eiweiß 100
milliliter milch ein viertel teelöffel
salz 1 esslöffel zitronensaft ein
viertel teelöffel natron 20 gramm
speisestärke 250 gramm doppel rahmen
frischkäse 140 gramm zucker 50 gramm
butter und 60 gramm kuchen mehr das
müsst ihr nicht extra kaufen damit nimmt
ihr euch einfach 54 gramm mehl und sechs
gramm speisestärke und sieht das fünf
mal hin und her
[Musik]
als allererstes habe ich mir meine top
wasser aufgekocht und gäbe da meine
schüssel drüber dann gebe ich da doppel
rahm frischkäse butter und milch hinein
und lasse das langsam schmelzen
[Musik]
und während die mischung schon mal
abkühlt nehme ich mir mein eiweiß und
schlage das mit dem nationalstolz
der kommt dann anschließend noch der
zucker hinein und dann wird das noch
weitere drei bis vier minuten lang
gemixt
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir die abgekühlte
frischkäse mischung und rühre da die
eigelbe hinein
jetzt kommen noch die restlichen zutaten
hinein einmal der zitronensaft das salz
die kuchen mehr mischung und auch die
speisestärke und dass sie mich noch mal
und die ganzen zutaten wendet sorgfältig
mit dem schneebesen verrühren
als allerletzten schritt gebe ich jetzt
noch die eiweiß zucker bzw die baiser
masse in drei schritten zu dem
restlichen teig rührt das in aller ruhe
unter und versucht nicht die ganze luft
raus zu schlagen
[Musik]
anschließend nehmen wir uns unser tiefes
backblech und geben da unsere
vorbereitete springform hinein das
backpapier dienen dazu das detail hoch
button kann und die alu folie dient dazu
dass der teig gleichmäßig packt um das
optimale ergebnis zu bekommen füllen wir
jetzt noch das backblech mit wasser ca 2
cm hoch und dabei müsst ihr darauf
achten dass eure springform auch dicht
ist damit der teig nicht auslaufen kann
nach genau 60 minuten bei 160 grad
unterschied zum ofen sieht man kuchen
nicht so aus und ich finde ihn mega mir
hat es sehr viel spaß gemacht diesen
kuchen zu backen und bei den nach backen
möchte der darf gerne einen kommentar
schreiben wie er geschmeckt hat und ob
er denn auch so gewackelt hat ich würde
mich freuen wenn nämlich abonniert damit
ihr beim nächsten mal auch nichts
verpasst ob die gis kutschen
ich würde mal sagen konditor